restaurer de manière traditionnelle une
charpente historique sous les fenêtres
de françois 1er le pari a séduit une
trentaine de professionnels tous
bénévoles à l'image d'alexandre avenue
de picardie et qui a rejoint
l'association à l'origine du projet là
je fais un ca meilleur
c'est une des pièces qui vient soutenir
la charpente qui se posent sur la
maçonnerie et voix qui va accueillir les
autres pièces de bois par dessus j'avais
toujours travaillé dans les entreprises
industrielles
et là elle fait de travailler à à la
main
st portent un
grave un nouveau rapport à son outil à
la matière au genre ici point de
matériel a été semé des outils utilisés
par des générations de bâtisseur
français anglais ou italien chacun
apporte sa pierre à l'édifice en toute
humilité moi je connais le piquage une
technique pour tracer les pièces de bois
donc les novices qui connaissent pas ça
on leur ment ou les anglais ou les amis
des etats-unis mais comme mme sahlin
want leur technique nous on leur montre
les techniques françaises à un chantier
participatif à ciel ouvert entièrement
dédié à la rénovation de la chapelle
saint-hubert et dont le bois a été
soigneusement choisis à seulement deux
kilomètres du château on travail du bois
verre du bois fred c'est très important
à savoir en charpente traditionnelle on
ne travaille pas du bois sec ond les
caries avec avec des haches c'est ce
qu'on voit sur ce chantier et puis
conformément à ce qui existait en 1840
dans la charpente que nous restons
beaucoup de pièces sont travaillés à
l'acide l'on peut dire qu'on sépare dans
la longueur des deux pièces pour obtenir
deux de mes pièces de quoi redonner sa
superbe à ce joyau architectural qui
abrite le tombeau de léonard de vinci
mais dont la structure risquer de
s'affaisser la restauration faite par
louis philippe en 1940 a été prévu pour
un toit en zinc beaucoup plus léger et
bien en 1870 dans les années 70 c'est
bien on choisira de remplacer ce toit
aux 1 qui est à bout de souffle par une
couverture en plomb ou plus étanche mais
beaucoup plus lourde le 19 tonnes un
chantier d'un montant de 2,7 millions
d'euros financé aux trois quarts par
l'état et qui devrait s'achever dans
deux ans